welcome to the GE cloak Liam in
sustainability leadership we're thrilled
to have two great panelists here today
to discuss corporate water stewardship
I'd like to take a moment to thank GE
the Center for Business and the
environment at Yale and my classmate
Aaron Willis for how they make this
event possible I'd also like knowledge
and thank the viewers who are joining us
today via the livestream our first
presenter Greg Koch has over 25 years of
experience in the environmental
engineering fields he is a bachelor of
science in mathematics from Columbus
College a Bachelor of civil engineering
from the Georgia Institute of Technology
and a Masters of Science in civil
engineering also from the Georgia
Institute of Technology he first joined
the coca-cola company in 1996 where he
managed the company's wastewater
treatment design construction and
operations program greg has been
instrumental in driving the company to
expand its water focus from technical
compliance to taking proactive measures
directed toward the sustainability of
its business worldwide currently Greg
leads the company's global water
stewardship he collaborates with
bottling partners governments NGOs and
communities throughout the coca-cola
system and directs his team toward
achieving the company's global goal to
return to communities and to nature the
amount of water equivalent to what is
used in all of its beverages and their
production also known as water
neutrality our second presenter jocelyn
casio is the supply chain environmental
and social governance or ESG manager at
Intel Jocelyn works internally and
externally to integrate ESG more deeply
into Intel supply chain and to define
increased expectations for its suppliers
Jocelyn has spent her entire 17-year
tenure at Intel in various roles in the
supply chain arena leading business
process improvement and change
management efforts on a variety of
global initiatives like contingent
workforce eprocurement and environmental
compliance
Jocelyn is a Lean Six Sigma certified
black belt with a BA in organizational
communication from Arizona State
University and an MBA from babson
college before I pass things over to the
panelists I would also like to introduce
our illustrious moderator for the day
Brad gentry is a professor in practice
here at the Yale School of Forestry and
environmental studies he's also Co
director at the Center for business in
the environment at Yale director of
research the research program on private
investment and the environment Brad's
work explores the opportunities for
using private investment to improve
environmental performance his
cross-sectoral work focuses on the steps
policymakers can take to develop
opportunities for sustainable
investments including market frameworks
information systems and shared
investments and partnerships he has
written extensively on the link between
private investment and environmental
performance including the book private
capital flows and the environment
lessons from Latin America with that I
pass the microphone over to our first
presenter Greg Koch
thanks for the introduction and thanks
to aaron willis for the initial
engagement i had with yael and
ultimately to all of you in Yale
University for allowing me to take part
in this much appreciated first of all I
just want to say that your school the
forest school is well represented in the
world that I work in it is quite often
that I run into somebody who preceded
you in this school FES at the World Bank
at other industries at WWF in fact the
most remote place I've ever been in all
my travels and I've been to over a
hundred countries and most of them many
many times was in northwestern
Mozambique on the banks of Lake niassa
like Malawi and met Caroline Simmons a
former graduate of your program here and
she was working for WWF as well as USAID
and so you're well represented geography
wise as well so I'm going to walk you
through three elements of my
presentation the first is going to be a
little bit around the background of
water and how we understand it and what
are some of the issues the second is a
little bit about how we've developed a
strategy and aligned our system to
respond to those stresses and then the
third part is going to be just a brief
review of the progress that we've made
in the execution of that strategy so the
first part of course is the stress that
water is under and it is under
significant stress most people when they
think about that they start to think
about droughts or floods the big drought
in Australia the water rationing from
the drought currently ongoing in Brazil
and of course the big drought in
Southern California right now which is
unfortunately going to get worse as the
summer comes along or they think about
floods
or very gross contamination very high
levels of contamination but that is
certainly a part of the water stress
that that the world faces and business
and society faces but as you can see
from the list it it's quite an evolved
topic it's a quite involved topic when
you look at how water moves through
economies through ecosystems and how
dependent of course we all are on water
for life and so when you take a broader
view it is the developed world as well
as the developing world that are facing
these stresses we as the company those
dots you see you could see a little bit
more clearly here operate in all but two
countries we're not in Cuba when we're
not in North Korea we've got two plants
at Myanmar a plant in South Sudan we run
a very local non export business but in
the context of this presentation what
that does for us is it makes us a canary
in the coal mine if you understand the
analogy in that we're facing these
stresses across our business operations
and having to respond to them and so
we're seeing the mix of these stresses
and the compounding effect of these
stresses in developed as well as
developing markets we also back to that
slide at the bottom right we run one of
the largest store have one of the
largest agricultural ingredients supply
chains in the world when you look at the
products that go into our finished
beverages you quickly realize that it's
agriculture so we're the largest buyer
of of course all kinds of sweeteners
corn sugar cane sugar beet but all kinds
of juices number one mango apple grape
orange lemon lime grapefruit lots of
stone fruits cherries apricots peaches
huge buyer on the global market and
locally as well as number two in the
world in tea and in coffee number three
and so when you think about where is
water being used in the world 70 odd
percent on
mobile average basis is in agriculture
so these stresses in our response to it
get amplified beyond just our direct
operations but into our market places as
well as into this vast agricultural
ingredient supply chain and so the way
we most commonly experience these
stresses or they manifest themselves at
least in the public realm is the human
health impact you've probably read the
figures but you have a billion people
plus they don't have access to safe
drinking water more people have a laptop
computer in the world and you've got a
third of humanity about two and a half
billion people that don't have access to
sanitation facilities so it's it's
outside is where they go more people
have a mobile phone a cell phone then
have access to what you would call a
porta potty or latrine or an outhouse
never mind you know a fancy restroom or
what have you so there's a huge human
health impact which is constricting of
course development education and
contributing to social strife and
security and conflict issues and as I
said this is not just a developing world
issue it's as much a developed world
issue and the issues that we face some
are stark and rising like emerging
contaminants but they typically fall in
in areas of infrastructure scarcity or
flood and so if you've been to Las Vegas
and you've seen the Hoover Dam this is
what the Hoover Dam is holding up as
Lake Mead so huge civil works project if
you've ever been out there it's the
colorado river flowing through there
well this is what it looks like in its
upper reaches a fact that is almost
complete now and they started five years
ago the city of Las Vegas is building a
tunnel to access the bottom of Lake Mead
because the water exit points for both
power generation and the intake points
for municipal water supplies are very
close to being hung
dry out of the water and so to ensure
from a long-term standpoint the ability
to get whatever water is left and lake
mead they have built this tunnel and
they're almost complete to go under Lake
Mead to extract the water instead of
trying to have it flow over or beneath
the damn Nashville Tennessee this was a
72 year flood if you understand flood
rankings from a zoning standpoint and a
stormwater management standpoint and you
could see that a 72 year flood
completely trumps the amount of
stormwater management they had so though
nning laws regulations the amount of
pavement have all conflicted with the
realities of storm events this same
event in well first of all in this place
it shut down our business for two weeks
because the municipal water and sewage
facilities both of them were under water
we couldn't operate and we were out of
business for two weeks that same flood
in Atlanta just show a hands when I say
72 year flood hundred year flood does
everyone kind of get that okay the one
in Atlanta we had a similar flooding
event like this it shut down the
interstates much of the city it took
several days for the regulators for noah
for the local weather people everyone to
come back and say what flood was is it
was a 500-year a thousand year 10,000
year it was none of those it was off the
charts it was a flood of people or a
rainfall event an intensity event a
duration of unprecedented magnitude so
you're starting to see elements of
climate change figure into the actual
stresses that we already face around
water and of course this continues
London I was actually in Hungary when
they had this mining tailings pond
collapse and the contamination that that
caused but when you look at the trend so
what I've said to date is the
establishment of lots of water stress
that exists today and these are being
exacerbated primarily by three factors
population growth
economic development and of course
climate change and in some places one of
these factors plays in more than the
other but you think about it how
population is growing we got more people
and so population will grow faster
somewhere around nine billion people
mid-century 2050 maybe earlier a
historic rise of people out of abject
poverty into the lower middle class
which is a good thing think of all the
people in India Brazil China Indonesia
that have come out of day-to-day
subsistence living into the lower middle
class but that's a much more resource
intensive lifestyle resources of all
kinds including water think processed
food more protein more manufactured
goods apparel beverages yes what have
you and so that is putting an added
resource on on already stressed water
supplies and then of course climate
change adaptation is not about getting
used to 2 degrees centigrade warmer
temperatures as much as it is a much
different unpredictable situation with
regard to water so as my favorite slide
that pulls those three together this is
a water park in Szechuan province in
south central China and so what are you
seeing here are you saying population
growth there's you know a billion plus
people in China you're seeing economic
development a dirt poor farmer anywhere
in the world cannot afford to to go to a
water park and so it's a national
geographic slide but I love putting it
together because you could you know sort
of imply its hot climate change so it
speaks volumes a bit of humor is I love
the guy who whose daughter or son
convinced him to bring that little
alligator thinking they would be able to
to float around in this big pool around
that but anyway I mean that that's the
reality of what a rising income level
does as well as population growth you
put a lot of stress on the resources
that are stressed to begin with and so
what that leads to is is not going to
change the water equation in the world
there's a fixed amount of water just
like there's a fixed or finite amount of
oil or coal but water is unlike those in
that it's infinitely renewable of course
but what will change is the rate of
those stresses over the next 10 20 30
years and so here's a slide that comes
from our modeling and all of this you
can find even more updated and more
comprehensive in the World Resources
Institute aquaduct water risk management
program there's some people here from
that program but that rate of change so
think about a meter sea-level rise if
that meter sea level rises in a thousand
years well that gives species human and
otherwise and ecosystems time to adjust
but if you get a meter sea level rise in
ten years that's a whole different rate
of change and so human species economy
societies whatever do not adapt well to
rapid rates of change and so we're
amplifying existing stresses in a very
short time frame which is going to
exacerbate the problems that we already
have so that's a little bit about water
and sort of the macro view so what does
it mean for us and the most important
point on this slide is the last point we
ran on export business so I mentioned a
thousand manufacturing plants in all the
two countries well we're not making a
car in in Mexico to ship to Detroit
we're not getting an education at Yale
University to then go out into the world
right where those are different business
models and they they work for for Yale
and for GM and Ford they work for other
beverage companies think of where your
wine and premium beers come from
alcohols most processed food there's a
handful of places around the world
pharmaceuticals and then the finished
products are shipped around the world
our business model doesn't work that way
the price point that our beverages sell
at and the business model that we found
most successful is local ownership
manufacturing sourcing and distribution
and so when you you take those
operations our response from from a
water standpoint is not about we need to
get enough water for our operations it's
yes we need water of sufficient quantity
and quality but we have to understand
and play a role a positive role in the
broader watershed and communities that
were a part of because they are our
marketplace it's who we're selling our
product to so this transcends corporate
social responsibility and it's not
embedded in our structure the way we we
execute our strategy on water it is a
business imperative a material risk and
so it is yes altruistic in some senses
the work that we do it is the benefit
sorry to society but it's all driven
from a fundamental business model in a
business risk which makes our response
to those issues very sustainable so as
long as we have a business we're going
to play a very positive role in helping
societies that we're a part of these
communities and the watersheds we share
with them to have enough water speed up
a bit the risk assessment that we
conducted so we came out of this
realization this has been an evolution
of maturity if you will of understanding
at the very local level these water
stressors and how they are changing and
being amplified over time we then made
it relevant to our business in terms of
understanding our supply chain our
manufacturing process and our non export
business model so that gave us the
relevance but neither of those are
actionable you know it's like going to
the doctor and saying okay I've got my
checkup and I've got my blood pressure
and all my blood work and it's just a
it's a report card you have to develop a
deeper understanding of the actual risks
that you face from that data set to be
able to develop a strategy so the the
next step of our journey was to do a
very comprehensive
risk assessment to develop ideas of
event initiators their probabilities
frequencies consequences and ultimately
impact which is what you do every day
like using the personal health care
analogy because you do that right you
get your doctor report and you sort of
think well maybe I ought to lower my
blood pressure and why because I could
have a heart attack well what's bad
about that I could die I could have a
stroke and have my lifestyle and earning
potential diminished my quality of life
you do it really quickly you do it every
time you cross the street you do a
formal risk assessment what's the
likelihood consequences impact and you
decide to cross the street or speed or
run that stop sign so it's something we
all do on a routine basis but when you
quantify and do it more rigorously which
business does all the time we apply that
same methodology to water and it
identified at the plant level at a very
granular level the specific risks that
we're finding which helped us develop a
strategic response to that so these are
the broad global roll up of that type of
work but we could pull that down to a
square kilometer resolution in terms of
the data that we put together to be able
to do this and that lets us now develop
a strategy so now we we have this so
back to the human health care analogy
okay so now I got my report I've done a
risk assessment what am I going to do
about it well I'm going to lose weight
I'm going to stop smoking I'm going to
take some medication exercise what have
you I've got a strategy and ultimately I
might set some goals for responding to
that risk or mitigating that risk and
this is the next three slides are the
three most important from the coke from
my perspective because they explain in a
nutshell our overall approach so this
strategic response said yes we have to
work in our upstream ingredient supply
chain and of course in our own
operations on water management
efficiency wastewater treatment run off
all those types of issues but that we
have to extend that type of
understanding and response
the watersheds that we share to the
communities that were a part of and then
ultimately on a broader stage at the
policy level and in the general
education and awareness level so that
that's the strategy and once we have
that strategy and spent enough time on
capacity building we were able to set
goals and this slide marked progress
against those goals the first to being
around water efficiency and wastewater
management in our business the next to
being about a quantification of how
we're progressing and mitigating that
risk so think of that as going back for
a checkup and seeing how your blood
pressure is doing and then this concept
of replenish which you heard it in the
introduction and I'll spend a little bit
of time on and we'll talk about it in
the panel discussion afterward but I
want to say that all this was possible
because of the capacity building so this
speaks to academia and to education we
had to develop a skill set across our
business for plant level people supply
chain managers business managers finance
managers a broad swath of
cross-functional teams to be able to
execute that strategy at the tactical
level so we needed to build capacity on
partnerships partnership formation
stakeholder identification and
engagement of course the science and
social and conservation science around
water issues so what we ended up doing
is developing a training program and its
online that can be self-paced it can be
facilitated classroom styles it has
three light it takes all those topics
from policy to community engagement to
hydrology to geochemistry whatever the
case may be a very broad swath of topics
that are relevant to this and there's
three levels of education I'd like to
call them throw the bachelor's master's
and PhD level and you choose what level
/ what topic based on your role and
responsibilities in the organization as
well as the amount of risk
you're facing and we have some guidance
to help people go through that it's in
seven different languages and we've done
well over a hundred thousand different
training modules that have been scored
and people have gone through that
process and that is part of the
governance that we have around our
source protection program to build that
capacity so that was the last step it
was this huge education effort over a
period of four years again back to the
the health care knology analogy okay so
you want to lose weight you want to
improve your diet and that's part of
your strategy based on your risk
assessment well you've got to go talk to
a dietician and understand nutrition
better you have to join a gym and learn
how to use the machines and hopefully
can get coordinated enough to do
aerobics which I can't do so it follows
along in a very logical fashion that
that's the next step and a lot of these
happens somewhat in parallel but the
importance I want to point out here is
that the humongous investment we made
and continue to make and sustain in in
capacity building within our business
system so now that you know what the
risks are and strategically how to
respond and you've built some capacity
you have to decide what am I
specifically going to do and of course
in every situation there's a whole range
of options and this is only a partial
list this doesn't get into municipal
infrastructure and leak detection and
management safe water access policy
engagement awareness-raising so there's
a lot of different things that you can
do and this is a simplified version of
the model that we use to help make that
decision on what to do we we have some
form or level and detail of data of
knowledge of the risks that we're facing
so there's a collective I'm sorry I use
my hands too much there's a collective
understanding of that that then points
to the underlying driver of that risk
and it's typically going to be a
combination of
something in those those several boxes
that you see there but something around
ecological health as well as as human
health or a mix of those that then allow
us to point to specific activities that
will help address those and those are
the four broad categories under
education and awareness you could add
policy policy engagement is sort of the
fastest part fastest-growing part of our
response work to to risk mitigation and
in the course of that we've this is the
last part of the presentation had some
progress you saw some on the progress
slide in terms of the goals that we've
set and how we're progressing against
those but another way of looking at it
is this concept of replenish and so
there we are tying the quantitative
impact of all the projects that we do in
communities in watersheds whatever the
case may be to our product volume and
we're doing that not to to to sort of
say that's all we have to do but it is
an easy way to convey to people the
progress that we're making and it's a
goal that will never attain never
attained in the sense that we could
reach a hundred percent but the minute
we sell more product we have to maintain
that level of a hundred percent
replenish so as our business grows
organically or by acquisition or if a
project that we execute it falls out of
productive service we have more to do so
it's it's a self-serving goal in that
you have to reach and maintain it we're
about halfway there but then you you
have to attain it but then you have to
maintain it as your business grows and
as those projects need to be sustained
and in the course of doing that I think
this is the third big important slide
that I talked about is the need for
partnerships in a lot of my role is a
way from my roots and technical and
engineering and whatnot but it's it's
working with governments communities and
in all cases through partnerships these
are some of our bigger partnerships that
myself and my team
but we're not an NGO we're not an aid
and development agency we are not the
government and so when we step outside
the four walls of our plant and want to
engage on those types of issues we have
to do that openly transparently and in
partnership thank you hi and I'll start
with adding my thanks as well for
inviting us here today to participate in
this forum very happy to be here I'm
actually based at our Massachusetts
facility just west of Boston and as
mentioned in the intro my background is
really in supply chain management so I
have one slide on that but we'll cover
the overall corporate water strategy
information here to begin with and then
wrap up with supply chain I assume many
of you are familiar with Intel we've got
about a hundred thousand employees at
this point spread across the globe and
our major manufacturing sites are here
on this map so the red dots are our
wafer fabs so that's where you will see
the majority of our water use because
that's very specifically tied to the the
cleaning of the silicon wafers during
the manufacturing process the white dots
are where we have assembly and test
facilities so those tend to be lower
water use sites broadly speaking when we
look across the globe at all of our
water usage and that currently stands at
about 9 billion gallons a year right now
i'll talk more about that another couple
of slides about 80% of what we use is
currently sent back to the local water
sources where it can be reused and again
I've got got more detail on that but big
picture wise about eighty percent is
essentially sent back to the
municipalities where we operate the 45
billion number is actually a little out
of date where we're closer to 50 billion
at this point in terms of what we've
been able to save through a variety of
programs again I'll share some details
in the past decade or so and are
spending on water programs is
is well over a hundred million dollars
at this point and growing so we've also
set a goal a little bit of tied to what
break shared for Coke by 2020 we're
looking to get back down below are
normalized per chip water usage numbers
from 2010 so both are absolute and our
normalized usage has been increasing
over the past several years that's tied
to the increasing complexity in the
fabrication process so as our technology
moves forward what comes with that is a
lot of additional typically rinsing of
the silicon wafers so again we feel this
is a very aggressive goal yet at this
point we are on track and we feel it's
realistic through additional focus and
investments so Intel's about a 45 year
old company and this whole notion of
embedding and integrating and having a
strong water strategy is one that's
really been around from the beginning so
the statement at the top is from our
Chairman at the time Gordon Moore and
this was from 95 so this was our
actually first annual environmental
report that we published and this was
right around the time where we were
really starting to grow our
manufacturing operations in places like
Arizona in Israel right which again
we'll talk more about as I move along so
I'm certainly not a new notion that we
really need to consider and integrate
water as well as other environmental
variables as we grow our operations the
bottom quote is from last year CSR
report our outgoing CEO Paul Otellini
again really reinforcing that executive
commitment to ongoing responsibility we
just in terms of kind of culturally it
until we really look at very broadly
environmental social and governance
factors typically under one umbrella so
you know we're here obviously
specifically to talk about water but I I
just want to point out that again social
issues in general governance ethics
topics those all tend to be looked at
very holistically when we look at our
operations and where we want to continue
to improve okay so a couple of facts
that is just a point of comparison there
one of our Ivy Bridge chips even that
being a couple of years old at this
point roughly the size of a grain of
rice and in terms of the numbers of
transistors and how fast those are able
to to compute it's just to kind of give
an appreciation for the the pace of the
technological advancement and the scale
the very small scale at which all of
this is happening so ultimately as the
technology increases one of the biggest
impacts is actually the the energy
conservation the reduction in energy
that it takes relatively speaking for
that increased amount of computing power
so that's something that I think the ICT
industry as a whole can have probably
the most significant impact on beyond
our own operations beyond our supply
chain efforts as an industry with that
energy efficiency we can really enable
massively greater and results and
impacts whether its water electricity or
otherwise so okay so a couple of points
on our overall approach to water over
the years so again corporate commitment
from the top level for for many years
I'll actually briefly show our water
policy which we updated most recently in
2010 we also have done pretty
comprehensive water footprinting over
the past several years I have some more
details to share in the next couple of
slides we have done a lot locally at
those fab sites around the globe
especially the ones where we're talking
about deserts like Arizona again I'm
going to share some more of that the
site selection process very much
considers not only water but again all
environmental factors so as we decide
where
the next fab is going to be this is
really something that is truly top of
mind and i'll talk about how how we make
some of those decisions and what we look
at again the 2020 goals I've mentioned
already and then continuous improvement
so as an engineering company this is
really something that's part of our DNA
no matter really what department you're
in whether it's technical or
non-technical there is this very
data-driven very I'll say committed
commitment to always looking to improve
and that's certainly extends to our work
in water as well Greg mentioned some of
their external partnerships and
collaborations we do a lot of that also
a couple of these are mentioned here and
I hope these slides are made available
because a lot of these are links and be
happy to to share more on that after
afterwards and then transparency again
another thing that that Greg brought up
so really making sure that we are being
as open as possible publicly engaging
with shareholders NGOs local and
national governments we actually this
explore until website is kind of
interesting this has been out for a
couple of years if anyone's familiar
with some of the environmental
challenges we've had at our new mexico
facility rio rancho was actually created
largely in response to some of our
neighbors concerns in that rio rancho
area about some of our factories
emissions so what this explore intel
site has grown to be is essentially
real-time data monitoring including
cameras that sit on the roofs of all of
our manufacturing facilities around the
globe at this point with real-time
readings on factory emissions so if you
were wondering what our dolly on china
facility was emitting right now you
could pull it up and and see that data
and see a view of those stacks at the on
the factory roofs real time so that's
something that we've done i think to
really because we really do value and
understand that transparency is critical
not only for us but for a lot of our
stakeholders
okay this is not intended to be right
it's a bit of an eye chart but again the
links here so feel free to peruse it but
again this is our current water policy
very deeply embedded again you'll see
reference to the Intel code of conduct
our supplier code of conduct all of this
is very very embedded across our
operations okay here's a peek at our
current water footprint so as I
mentioned current usage as a end of year
2012 we're just finishing the 2013
calculations but 2012 usage was at about
9 billion gallons annually this flow is
intended to just show obviously where
where that goes and where we're able to
either reuse replenish or recycle
various along various parts of the flow
so we've been water footprinting now for
the past three years we've engaged with
Qantas over the past two years to really
try to again bring some external
stakeholder perspective and expertise to
our footprinting and also to make sure
that we're really able to prioritize and
drive our next round of continuous
improvement based on some really
extensive external expertise as well so
we've published a couple of I Triple E
papers one co-authored with Qantas over
the past couple of years that are out
there and the most recent one actually
diving a little bit more deeply into a
scope 2 and 3 water usage as well so
there this is included in our annual CSR
report again another key way we try to
be transparent and share what's going on
with our stakeholders ok another bit of
an eye chart but this is what has come
from the 2012 engagement again with
Qantas so the idea here is again
recognizing the fact that we've got
operations in a lot of arid locations
around the globe really trying to get
our arms around the true impact
of having fabs in those areas so the
first column is very straightforward
it's just the volume of water used the
second is based on the water stress
index and the idea is that we can better
understand the potential for impacts in
these locations where we have these fabs
using large volumes of water columns
three and four are really more detailed
and based on very specific local
pressures and local issues in the
communities where these fabs are located
so daily is disability adjusted life
years and the values here help us to
determine where we need to to take more
action so the value here doesn't
necessarily mean that Intel's operations
are driving or the only factor in this
potential impact but it does help us
figure out when and where we need to do
more so Vietnam is an example with the
19 value we knew going into that
facility and that's our newest assembly
test facility it's been operational for
just a couple of years we knew we had to
do more engagement there before we
brought up our operations so the high
tech Park where our site is located we
actually did a lot on the ground to make
sure that the overall infrastructure was
improved sufficiently before we started
operating so that once we got there we
didn't have to you know have any
unpleasant surprises so again site
selection looked at this very early on
and we were able to proactively work
with the local government and our
neighbors in that high tech Park to make
improvements I was actually just there
about a month ago and early in January
The Wall Street Journal did an article
recognizing specifically the Vietnam
site as being a really strong really
role model in terms of the overall
sustainability of the site so I know
that was a really big deal and site
management was you know very very
pleased to see that again you know being
proactive had ultimately resulted in
what we had hoped and that is avoiding
some of the potential issues okay so
this is an Arizona
case study so Arizona typically is what
we get asked about the most so whether
it's during one of our socially
responsible investor road shows that we
do every year or just through ongoing
NGO or other stakeholder dialogue
Arizona tends to be what people ask
about so we've got three fabs there now
and generally without any actions taken
what we would essentially withdraw from
that city of chandler source is 8.9
million gallons a day so this is just
that that standard picture if we did
nothing this is what it would look like
at our operations in Arizona however
since about nineteen ninety six we've
had a really good program in place again
that's been continuously improving but
we engaged with the city of chandler so
Chandler's the the town in Arizona where
all of these fabs reside and over these
years we've actually been able to
conserve and put back into the aquifer
over five billion gallons of water
through this program with the city so
essentially intel funded the development
of an RO wastewater plant and again
worked with them to initially just with
that particular effort reduce our demand
by about 1.1 million so somewhere in the
neighborhood of a what fifteen maybe
twenty percent reduction then we've been
able to use reclaimed water so beyond to
the aquifer research recharge piece of
it we've been able to utilize over four
and a half billion gallons of treated
wastewater from Chandler to cool in the
cooling towers run the scrubbers in the
factory and also for the landscaping
which obviously in the desert does does
still even with desert landscaping
require some amount of irrigation so
that took us down by about another one
point nine million and then lastly
through internal reclaim and recycling
we're able to further reduce our need by
about another 1.1 million so lots of
projects
it's on an ongoing basis that not only
come from some of the technical experts
that you might expect to be working on
this kind of thing but we actually have
some really cool employee programs that
are just widely available to anyone who
has an idea for a sustainability project
so we've got some sustainability in
action grants that anyone from any
department can apply for if they've got
a proof of concept that they want to
explore or a pilot that they'd like to
get off the ground that they think can
help make an impact environmentally so
those have been really increasing in
terms of how many employees are applying
every year the impact of the projects
and the results that they're getting so
we see you know people from the finance
organization or from human resources or
from IT getting together with
manufacturing folks site and facilities
management folks and putting together
these teams just to apply for these
grants and ultimately end up driving a
lot of what what results in these pretty
big numbers in the end so that's been
pretty exciting to see so in the end in
Arizona based on the variety of efforts
over the years we are able to reduce our
usage by roughly fifty percent supply
chain the piece I'm most familiar with
again we look at as I mentioned ESG
criteria kind of all all together and
we've really had that fully integrated
into our supply chain management
practices for quite a number of years
now so as an example all suppliers in
their integrated scorecard are assessed
on how they're doing in this area and
that absolutely includes water as a
specific requirement contract terms and
conditions our supplier recognition
program all of these we've been able to
integrate a sustainability over the past
several years our top suppliers so we
have a group of about 300 suppliers with
which we spend probably about ninety
percent of our dollars every year we're
very specific with them in terms of
having to have multi-year water waste
and carbon goals and measurable progress
towards those and again if they don't
that's going to be reflected on their
scorecard and future business decisions
are going to be based on that alongside
other criteria and then I don't know how
many here have heard of the eicc
electronics industry citizenship
coalition one or two hands this is about
a 10 year old coalition that Intel
helped found together with Microsoft IBM
HP Dell a lot of the big players in the
industry it's grown to almost 90 member
companies today representing every tier
of the electronic supply chain going all
the way back to small components
manufacturers and all the way forward to
retailers like Best Buy and I think the
key thing as with most industry
associations is really trying to drive
some standards here so within the EIC
see code of conduct we have very
specific environmental expectations
embedded there and that means when we go
to audit our high-risk suppliers we're
asking about a lot of this in a lot of
detail so whether it's wastewater
treatment water conservation efforts
every time we have a third party go and
perform a supplier audit that's being
looked at all over the globe so it's
another way I think that represents the
overall integration so what have we
learned again over these past several
decades and and where are we today I
think being proactive and open-minded
has been obviously top of the list here
I think the New Mexico example I
mentioned earlier where we did for for a
number of years have some challenging
conversations with some of our neighbors
think we learned a lot from that and I
think that we continue to try to again
keep an open mind anytime it's a new
challenge that that we come upon
leveraging existing literature and
experts again that continuous
improvement culture that really
permeates everything we do transparency
again clearly a key driver and then make
sure we're staying in touch so we don't
want to let that foot printing activity
sit for a couple of years right we know
things are changing at a very fast pace
whether that's our own
internal operations or externalities so
really trying to to not wait and just
try to stay as ahead and be as proactive
as possible so thank you my contact
information here as is Tom Cooper's he's
actually our true global water strategy
lead and expert so he is available as
well and then Arceus our reports linked
here there's a lot out there if you
wanted some additional details thanks so
thank you both very much and look
forward to a nice amount of time for
questions what I thought we'd do is I'd
ask a couple of questions to get started
and then open it up to questions from
the audience one of the things that
struck me as you were talking was too
maybe dive a little bit of deeper into
some of the business case aspects for
the investments of time and money that
have been made you know thinking about
financial returns and brand returns and
other sorts of social or other returns
so Greg I might start with you know you
all as the part of the replenishment
goal are not just doing things at your
plant you're not just doing things in
your supply chain you're reaching out to
organizations in your watersheds how do
you about determining how far to go you
know how many organizations to link with
sort of watershed by watershed very good
question and we talked a little bit
about it at lunch for those that were
there you know water is the ultimate
public good and so at the end of the day
the scale at which water moves through
an economy a society and the integration
of water and everything that humans do
makes it this ultimate public good and
therefore it is government who
ultimately need
to step in and and set policy and then
enforce that policy all the way down to
regulations and codes and what have you
so that's why I mentioned in our
strategy the fastest-growing part of our
work is that policy engagement which we
do collectively and very transparently
which you really have to do because of
fears of policy capture so that's the
ultimate long-term play but in in
executing the specific strategies at the
plant level we use three measures to
sort of tell us how far to go the first
is is inherent in the in the goal that
we set and replenish and so the work
will be quantified in terms of its
beneficial impact and every business
unit every geographic grouping and an
operation in our system has a goal to
reach some are more than one hundred
percent some are less depending on the
local needs and stresses and so how much
you progress against replenish is one
way to value and and gauge how far you
need to go the second and arguably the
well they're all important depends when
you ask me another important measure of
how far to go is risk mitigation so when
you do risk mitigation you you have a
target you have a quantification of that
risk again in the healthcare example
it's it's the value of your life and the
quality of life that you have your
earning capacity what have you the same
happens in the type of risk assessment
that we did and so when you repeat that
you can actually do a cost of
cost-benefit analysis on the resources
you've expended against the amount of
risk that you've mitigated and so if you
trust your original numbers like you
trust your doctor you're going to do
things and and you know when to stop and
then the last is about and it's the
hardest one and it probably this this is
the most important it's it's it's our
licenses to operate
and it's sort of a reflection of all
that came before it and it's probably
our biggest learning certainly my
personal biggest learning when it comes
to water we need three licenses to
operate wherever we are our supply chain
uses water and the first is the
regulatory license and that that is what
you think it is it's the permits the
abstraction license the fees the
contracts whatever you have so that's
one measure if I'm maintaining that
that's one measure of how far I need to
go the second is the the physical
license and there is the hydrology the
hydrogeology the the sustainable supply
of enough clean water for you and your
marketplace right and so sometimes
that's utopian in thinking but that's a
way to go and then the last is the the
emotional license and I say that versus
the social license because water
actually goes beyond sort of the
construct of the social license to
operate because of how connected we are
with water spiritually physically
religiously even so that that social
acceptance of our use of water in the
political will to support it wrapped up
in that emotional license and so it's
securing and maintaining those three
licenses it's it is the the risk
mitigation benefit and the replenished
progress as the the proxies work for how
far to go great so Justin as you're
thinking about your example of having
the the water needed for the plant and
in Arizona did all of those investments
have to meet the same hurdle rate as all
of the investments in the company or do
you have sort of special lower hurdle
rates if there are these public benefits
or the emotional license to operate type
of issues that are out there yeah great
question so first I'll just say our view
on the license to operate piece is
pretty consistent right that it's a
complex scenario not as simple as kind
of the permitting process but generally
speaking where will typically be a
little more generous as in the ROI
I timeframe so not so much in you know
funding a lot that's negative ROI but
more say for example allowing up to a
ten year time frame versus something
operationally that might need to be more
and a 325 type of year and that's not a
hard and fast rule but when we look at
things like those sustainability in
action grants when we look at some of
our renewable energy purchases that's
something that we will typically take a
little bit longer term view one so maybe
one last round and then I'll open it up
for questions and they'll be microphones
going around so you've both got these
wonderfully ambitious targets you know
for for coca-cola water neutrality by
2020 for Intel we're taking your per
chip water use back to to 2010 by 2020
what are the biggest barriers to
achieving those maybe we start with
great oh sure the biggest barrier for us
early days I would have said alignment
with our system but the way we went
through this process of you know similar
to the presentation that i gave of
discovering or learning about the water
stresses and then developing a strategic
response and that executing that made
that alignment possible across our
business system so when I say we I'm
talking about our franchise bottling
partners as well as the company's
operations on a global basis because we
all share the same brand even though
they may not report up through atlanta
and the coca-cola company but that was a
significant factor in planning for the
future is that internal alignment which
came from the co discovery and code
development of both the underlying data
and and the strategic response to that
the biggest challenge I think going
forward is a round collective action in
public policy I don't see the big
challenge being in us attaining our
goals we do apply the same internal rate
of return
to cost of capital thresholds for our
work and we can quantify that against
our risk assessment and we've been
successful to date so I'm confident that
we'll we'll reach our goals it'll be a
challenge maintaining that level going
forward but us meeting our goals isn't
going to solve the water crisis crises
that exist in all these places and so
the bigger challenge is how much more do
you do because you may have made your
impact sustainable or positive in that
sense but that hasn't mitigated the
overall stress and I gave from watershed
and so the big challenge is going to be
how to build a consensus from a broader
set of of actors industry as well as
government and civil society to to
amplify the type of work that we're
doing do you mind if I just ask a
follow-up on that so you talked about
building the political consensus
essentially in the policy framework is
that going to need to be done watershed
by watershed or is there something that
can usefully be done at the global level
or a regional level or or other thing
like that at the end of the day you need
to do it on the sub-basin level and
that's that's where people experience
water issues that's where they interact
with water and for the most part that's
where it's regulated so you have to fill
the data gaps at the sub-basin level so
if you're in Connecticut you don't
really care how much water is in the
United States or even in Connecticut you
care if you live in New Haven how much
is here and and the local municipality
I'm certain has a lot of a lot of
control on that and so that makes it
take more time but those global data
sets and even country level are great to
get started and identify hotspots but
you've got to fill that in at a very
local level particularly when you you
know the most powerful way we find is to
engage in this policy discussion is to
analyze and discuss how water moves
through an economy in its widest sense
from tourism to
actual productive uses of water what
have you transportation navigation
making coca-cola beverages or Intel
chips what have you and when you do that
then you have a frank or discussion more
candid one with all the stakeholders on
the choices of what you do with the
water that you have and how you manage
that and so putting it in something we
all share and that's the value of water
we may not fully appreciate it but we
certainly have it and then everyone
cares about finances and their
livelihood and their well-being and that
makes it manageable to get started
versus throwing your hands up and saying
it I just can't go that far it's too
detailed so if you need it sub-basin by
sub base and that's a lot of jobs so our
students should be sending you lots of
CDs yeah absolutely Jocelyn how about
for you and your biggest barriers so I
think first and foremost it really is
often a technology challenge for us so
we work with industry associations like
SEMATECH and SI a to try to really
collaborate and work for example with
our capital equipment suppliers so those
multi-million dollar pieces of equipment
that go out onto our factory floors a
lot of times those suppliers need to be
very involved with making that equipment
more efficient right using less water
again for the rinsing of the wafers as
they go through the manufacturing
process so we do work with suppliers on
an individual basis but then through the
industry associations really try to
drive non-competitive advancements so
that it's not a matter of just creating
you know competitive advantage when one
company is able to make progress and
another isn't but to try to really
collaborate and realize the benefits for
the industry as a whole so that's one
way as far as the technology challenge
goes that we try to approach it and then
it is a cost issue as well so again
sometimes that is helped by the
industry-wide efforts I want to share
though that we've been getting a lot
more creative and open-minded internally
than we ever have been in the past since
setting those 2020 goals
so our technology development factory
which is in Portland Oregon for the
first time with our couple generations
out of manufacturing processes that are
in development now have been much more
willing to consider options as far as
water goes that have always been off the
table in the past so I can't really
share the details on that but those are
some of the reasons why we do feel that
that very aggressive 2020 goal is still
realistic and achievable so internally
things that were previously sacred cows
that we would never talk about
considering are now on the table being
piloted and ultimately hopefully making
it to high-volume manufacturing
processes so that's been pretty
encouraging it's interesting the
difference there between the technology
barriers and the more political or
social barriers over time so maybe I'll
open it up to questions i've got a
microphone here and a microphone there
one in the front thank you people could
wait for the mic to show up and then
briefly state your name and your
organization so that the people watching
the live stream will know who is asking
the question I'm Tom we all I'm with
water health which is one of the coke
partners and there's huge overlap here
between what you guys are trying to do
which is incredibly hard and maybe you
want to spend a minute just telling
people about how tough it is in the
basin and on the ground to get these
things done but one of the frustrating
elements of opposition comes from NGOs
many of whom don't appreciate the role
the capital can play in solving these
problems and governments who have turf
issues and not any comments you have on
how you deal with those I'd be
interested in thank you thanks so I'll
take the second part first and turf
issues I can fully understand and
appreciate how that is a challenge for a
lot of businesses and I can't say that
we've cracked the code on that but when
you look at our business model again I
always go back to that because of how
foundationally important that is we're a
local business we're the largest private
employer in
in Africa for instance where the fourth
largest employer in the world and so all
those truck drivers all those people
working at the plants that's where most
of those are they're all locals as is
the general management and the marketing
manager and the supply chain manager so
we are an integral and long-standing
partner in those communities we
routinely engage with government civil
society schools what have you and so I
wouldn't say this is just an automatic
progression but it is an extension of
the types of relationships that we
already have their we still run into
that but we never go it alone we don't
go in as the coca-cola company to say
this is what I think you ought to do on
water policy it's we look for platforms
and partners to join us most notably is
our main thrust in the policy realm at
the country level is through a group
called the 2030 Water Resources Group
wrg it's housed in the IFC and it's a
multi-stakeholder platform of that type
of engagement at the country level well
who's a member of that yes we are so as
PepsiCo this is a pre-competitive issue
for us so Nestle's in there sabmiller
you know will compete on the marketplace
shelf but sustainable communities
starting with sustainable water systems
and how you manage them and resources is
pre-competitive and so we're right there
in other industry associations actually
working with Intel so that gets a little
bit at the the turf issues and
ameliorates that concern a little bit
that you're not coming in to capture
policy for your own purposes and you can
really demonstrate that when you walk in
with your chief competitor how hard is
this it is difficult Jennifer Hoyle if
she's in here but she was earlier i met
with her you know what I told her is
that the soft stuff is the hard stuff so
unlike the technology that you need to
achieve what you do in your business
model and there's a role for that in our
work but
that's not the that's not the crux of it
right in us meeting our goals and it's
not really the crux of solving most of
the world's water problems that's the
hard stuff the hard stuff the more
difficult thing to do is the soft stuff
it is policy engagement behavior change
capacity-building developing finance
networks developing a supply chain
sustainable incomes you know that type
of engagement over 3000 communities
where those 468 projects are being
executed that's that's the challenging
but also the very rewarding work
jessalyn maybe you could focus in on the
NGO side and the sort of range of
experience as you I'm sure have had with
NGOs and lessons learned from that yes
that's what i was thinking excellent so
so yes so sometimes NGOs can certainly
be collaborative but not always so we do
a couple of things to to try to have as
collaborative relationships as possible
so we do try to again be open even to
sitting down with some that come in with
very adversarial whether it's with a
shareholder resolution or otherwise and
really have an open open dialogue try to
come to some common ground and just try
to be willing to work with even if you
know on the surface that appears that
you know priorities are very different
or you know perspectives are very
different we do materiality assessments
on a regular basis and really try to
pull in lots of NGOs not just the ones
that we know to be business friendly
that we have ongoing relationships with
so we work with BSR a lot on a lot of
initiatives will pull them in but will
also pull in others that aren't
necessarily always at the top of our
list for you know wanting to engage with
so in that way we really try to make
sure that their voices are heard that
we're bringing in a really broad range
of perspectives and taking those into
account in that big picture assessment
of what our external stakeholders
priorities are and then I briefly
mentioned the SR I road shows that we do
every year so again that's not NGOs but
just engaging with that additional very
important
group of stakeholders I think it's been
almost ten years or so that we do a tour
every fall DC New York and Boston I've
been part of those meetings for the past
three years where we sit down after our
csr report comes out every year we go
into quite a bit more detail and really
try to get their feedback and trust me
some of them are very vocal very frank
and not shy about you know telling us
where you know hey this isn't you know
this isn't enough we've certainly heard
that water concerns raised in those
conversations so those are very open
candid dialogues that I think we also
feel are very sincerely important to
really balancing priorities and
understanding where those external
stakeholders are coming from i I'm Laura
slavin a second year at the Yale School
of Management thank you both for being
here you both come from organizations
that are very advanced with respect to
water stewardship and I wonder how you
balance the need to gain competitive
advantage with the need to collaborate
and move your industries forward to
solve the world's water problems Thanks
yeah I mean from us it from from the
coca-cola standpoint it's it's rather
straightforward it is a pre-competitive
issue so when we look at our business
model again back to that but we look at
the the stresses that that a watershed a
community a marketplace faces they're
the same ones that our operations their
face our response cannot be unilateral
because we don't we're not the
government we don't own the watershed we
don't we're not an NGO so we have to
partner with those elements but at the
end of the day we have to work with
other industry share our data and our
knowledge and seek collective action
you know what I didn't touch on in my
presentation was that a majority of
those partnerships that we have are not
just between us civil society and
government entities but also there's
more depth on the industry side so I
gave you the example of PepsiCo and the
water policy work together with Nestle
and others the same thing happens in
Toms the partnership we have with water
health international it's coca-cola and
Diageo which is a big brewer and alcohol
firm as well as some local businesses
working together with USAID and the IFC
so the issues are big and they're shared
and so the response has to be so I I
don't think that's the place for
competitive advantage if your ultimate
aim is the sustainability of those
supplies you know are you head to head
anywhere on you get water and I don't
get water well if it comes to that in
some places then then you're a different
situation but I think at that point most
industry is already out of the equation
I mean if you get down to I've got three
drops who gets them you know basic
hydration and sanitation are always
going to trump anything else that you
want to do yeah I think pretty
consistent thoughts I would have on this
subject again whether it's NGOs or or
otherwise industry associations again
looking to really try to make it not a
competitive advantage type of discussion
as much as possible to make it more
collaborative and I'll say open source
as many of the kind of tools and best
practices that we come up with as
possible is anyone familiar with water
match it's come out of Arizona State and
so we were very involved in that which
again reaches well beyond our industry
it's again kind of open source literally
publicly matching where there are water
needs and where there is water
availability so I think our views on
that are pretty similar let me test that
just a little bit about whether there's
a border that you might not cross so for
example Greg you talked a lot about your
great training program
and the online training program is that
available for anybody or is that limited
to coke people Jocelyn you talked about
the new technologies that you're
developing but you couldn't tell us much
about because they're in two areas
presumably there are aspects of how
you're managing your company's
activities in these areas that are seen
as sort of a competitive advantage or at
least one that you would keep
confidential and where does that line
get drawn toward yeah I I didn't mean to
paint the whole category with that brush
thanks for the difficult question okay
so there's two avenues for that I mean
there's things that we have developed
and and will do and Intel and PepsiCo
and other businesses with the same that
that are very unique to your business so
I talked about our risk model for
instance well it would do me no good to
give you my risk model because you have
the same water stress we're sitting here
in the same place but your risk is
different than my risk just as you know
me giving you my health data doesn't
help you form a strategic response to
your own personal health right so I'm
not trying to be vague hear what I'm
trying to say is that when you when you
go through this risk process it becomes
your risk you want it to become your
risk if it's a shared risk I don't think
that really exists we share stresses
we're breathing the same air but the
risks in terms of what they do are
different and so there is a there is a
room and there is a proper place for the
integration of what you're doing in this
water space with your business and if
you if you do it that way it's very
powerful because you're not speaking in
the abstract and at the 50,000 foot
level you're taking our day-to-day
business that everyone's familiar with
the finances the quality the volume and
you're marrying it with the realities
around water and that's important
because that gives you alignment and
really solid and sustained response and
so that makes it really hard to pull
that apart and say well you can see this
but you can't see that so to answer your
question specifically yes there are
things that we have built in
to our programs that make it difficult
so the the training program that I have
it is it is conducted and formatted in a
way that it is part of a broader
training program and so there is
confidential information but it is
something that we're looking at we have
we'd be happy to work with you I'm sure
yeah we have a couple years ago taken
the majority of the intellectual
property that we had all the data sets
all the shapefiles all this harvesting
of information the geo spatial and
temporal studies that we did that formed
the the data part of our risk assessment
and we donated all of that to the Water
Resources Institute as they began their
aquaduct water risk management program
they've since taken that to a whole
nother level but it was something that
we felt we had to do because we want the
collective action on watershed and so if
we if we have this type of data why not
share it with an independent neutral
source like like WRI or academia so we
have some aqueducts people in the
audience yes just for as questions
afterwards anybody who knows about
equity raise their hands just so people
know who is here and I okay great thanks
jocelyn i should give you a chance to
restore yeah and again I you know a lot
of agreement with with Greg I think as
far as our own manufacturing operations
go where we're still figuring things out
that's kind of what's not ready to be
shared because it's still pretty early
in the proof-of-concept face but I'll
give a specific example from supply
chains so we do we're doing more
actually this year in terms of supplier
capability building and sustainability
than we ever have in the past we've done
a two-day sustainability summit for our
china suppliers that we've held in
shanghai the past couple of years and
one thing we're doing there is really
trying to pull in other industries as
much as possible to share more across
different sectors again to try to
increase the pace of progress
in learning and actually just co-author
at a white paper with BS our last month
actually looking for ways to collaborate
cross-sector more frequently whether
that supplier capability building or
otherwise because I do feel like we you
know we probably have opportunities
where you know there's a best practice
you guys have figured out that may not
be a direct translation but surely you
know we can benefit by the work that
you've done and hopefully vice versa so
I think we're growing in terms of our
real focus in trying to do more whether
you call it open source or cross sector
you know public collaboration so I think
we're trending in that direction
straight yeah Christian the blue hi my
name is Colby Tucker I'm a master
student here at the school of Forestry
environmental studies thank you both for
your really interesting presentations
the thing that caught me most about your
presentations was the juxtaposition
between the water use business models
and how coax is very local and how
Intel's uses more of a global source and
ships it and so on one of the slides for
you Greg you had a agro protect and
sustain as a as a motto and I'm
wondering that in the future as climate
change becomes a bigger stress in order
to sustain your mission in reducing your
water use and returning water back to
the local areas do you think that you
might have to change your business model
in order to go to more water rich areas
and avoid those water poor areas yeah
two-part answer one is I don't know
that's not my purview in terms of
changing our business model because that
can't be done single variant Lee you
can't just say well because of the water
issues we're going to move too much how
the beer business in the US works you
know you look at it as oerba SH I think
they have seven or eight manufacturing
facilities around the United States and
then you get your beer from registry
they ship it all around the United
States right so there's a lot of factors
that go into creating business models is
water certainly one of them yes but it
would it be the main driver for changing
a business model that's that's above
that's above me I hope to be part of
those discussions if it gets to that but
there's a lot of other things in play
transportation transportation
infrastructure logistics carbon
footprint or shipping greater distances
what have you but but I what I can say
is that our source protection program
really where the meat of the data and
the response to that data comes from
there's a there's a premise to that
document it's an internal requirement so
the actual document that tells our
operations what you have to do not a
premise an introduction of purpose and
in that purpose we in fact I wrote it so
I state that it is not the purpose of
this document and all this work you have
to do and all this training you have to
do to ensure you get enough water
wherever you want as much as you want
for however long as you want words to
that effect it is certainly a document
to help you maintain your manufacturing
operations and sustain them but it
recognizes limits it says that this is a
shared environment and therefore there
are limits in in the physical nature as
well as as competing uses of that water
that may have higher priority so right
there we're acknowledging in the very
core of how we communicate and govern
this program internally with saying that
that's the underlying premise for
approaching this so but if it could have
changed a business model I don't know so
maybe I can ask jocelyn a related
question you thinking about sustaining
over time and the impact of climate
change and the sort of water energy
nexus and i gather that some of your
thinking about water requirements and
water footprinting is
been linked to renewable energy credits
yes where did that come from yeah very
much so so so obviously it takes a lot
of electricity to move water around
right that's a given and then as we got
into some of the deeper analysis in our
footprinting and in our strategy what we
really started focusing on was how much
water it takes to produce electricity
and so overall again focusing on the
energy efficiency of our operations the
energy efficiency that our products can
ultimately deliver to our end users when
you look at something like a data center
it's all obviously very interconnected
and we do look at it in a very
integrated holistic way I yeah I think
that's in general that's definitely
something that we've kind of shifted to
over the past couple of years yep maybe
one last question started in the hi my
name is corey johnson i'm here at the
forestry school i have a quick question
about the investor perspective i spent
several years at a sr mutual fund and i
know that in the end in the industry the
intel road shows are much appreciated
i'm wondering and this question for both
of you i'm wondering to what degree
traditional institutional investors are
taking these issues into consideration
are these our waters who's being talked
about on analyst calls some you know
among bigger institutional investors i
honestly don't know if water
specifically has come up but generally
speaking among not only the SR i but the
traditional investment community i would
say it's it's been continuously growing
over the past several years so as an
example supply chain has grown as an
interest among mainstream investors to
the point where we're being pulled into
a lot more conversations than we ever
have been so where things might have
been limited to asking about our own
operations that's just really grown in
scope quite a bit so whether that's
water labor obviously huge concern in in
the industry at the moment or again
ethics and governance types of issues
so I think one of the things that's
driving the change among more mainstream
investors is the addition of the ESG
content on Bloomberg which is just in
the past couple of quarters or late late
last summer I guess mid to late last
summer I was at a really interesting
conference in New York last August and
an analyst there was saying that it's
really essentially brought the topic of
ESG transparency to the forefront of a
lot of CEOs minds that it had not been
really even on the radar screen for in
the past because from a competitive
perspective if your peers got a bunch of
good content up there and you've got
nothing or you know very little by
comparison that that's really driving a
lot of disclosure and I think interest
just across the board and in terms of
mainstream investors Greg do you want it
absolutely I mean 10 years ago you would
only meet with the SR is a socially
responsible investment crimps on these
types of issues but now I mean I've got
a meeting April first in New York with
clear barrage advisors I meet with
blackrock I go to Boston routinely on
State Street with lots of different
institutional investors and then don't
forget I mean there's some that you
might put in the SR I category because
they are socially responsible in terms
of their investment strategies but
they're big think calpers CalSTRS the
the to California state employees and
teachers pension funds and to the
biggest pension funds in the world and
we routinely engage with them so it's
part of our disclosure in our 10 k's in
10 10 cues and 22 investors so they're
asking for it the SEC is requiring it
and similarly in other financial
jurisdictions and it is becoming more
top of mind it's not something that's
purely an SSRI field if you will one
more example that comes to mind actually
mainstream investor wise about two and a
half years ago there were a couple of
mainstream investor
filed shareholder resolutions with many
of the top brands in the electronics
industry ourselves Microsoft Dell HP
pretty much all had one or two of these
filed and the resolution was
specifically asking for us to require
our suppliers to publish a gri based csr
report so that was a really interesting
one for us just in terms of the fact
that it didn't come from an SRA it came
from you know to to mainstream investors
and the fact that it was again not
looking at our own operations but
wanting us to require because of our you
know size and scale require a supply
chain to do that increased amount of
disclosure so that was that was a pretty
pretty good one for us yeah I would just
end from my in on an academic note the
work that Dan st's and Yale has done on
performance indicators the the concepts
of valuation of a stock or an investment
you know want to qualify what I said
earlier a lot of people are talking
about this and it's moved well beyond
the SR I community into mainstream
investors and buy and sell side analysts
but how do you how do you go about
valuing a company what is the financial
analysis that you do and translating
everything we've been talking about and
more so water issues but carbon issues
others labor rights all those ESG type
responses into a traditional financial
evaluation to drive an investment
decision at least from that data set
that's work that still needs to be done
that has not been translated yet you
know so you could look at you know how
much data company has and what their
volume is and their operating income and
all those types of things so the next
great field is this concept of valuing
nature both from a capex standpoint as
well as from an optic standpoint and
that hopefully will move the needle down
the road to the type of disclosure that
would reflect that from companies but
then also the decisions that investors
would make about that and I would say
ultimately consumers about the products
they choose and I think things like the
dow jones sustainability
the index are trying to move in that
direction right but there's a lot of
progression and maturity that's still
still needed well that's a great
challenge with which to leave us and
thank you so much for answering our
questions and congratulations on the
progress your companies have made to
date and look forward to the future
thank you very much